I just had cheek swab, protocol update, and some questions.
Pectosol C. One scoop a day,
increased to three scoops a day.
Can this be done all at once in a smoothie?
Yes, you can.
It doesn't mix very well any other way.
Pectosol C will dissolve instantly in orange juice
or citrus juice, though.
So if you just need to take a couple ounces,
of course, that's sugar.
I know it's not necessarily good for you,
but take a couple ounces of orange juice.
You put it in there and literally dissolve like magic
and you could drink it down that way too.
But otherwise, everybody else puts it in a smoothie.
Dan Delay and Liquid take three table spoons a day.
It's split doses to the speed.
One table spoon, three different times a day.
Yes, so whatever I say, split doses,
that means try to split it up as best as you can.
But technically, a split dose of it's three tables
would a day be one table spoon three times a day.
But really, when I mean split doses,
it's just try to get it split up.
You take one and a half and then I can only do it
morning and evening.
I work full time, there's no way I could do it at work.
Or I forget my new and time,
then just split it up with two.
You wanted to have table split doses.
This section, I read this.
Green's first replacement's young jeopardy continue.
That's my mistake.
That should not say continue.
So, sorry about that.
The young jeopardy power did not powder
to not test well for you.
Don't drink green's first powder test well for you.
So, no, most people use these for a multiple vitamin.
We get all of your nutrition in.
But when it doesn't test for somebody,
then it's like, okay, what do you use?
Well, again, I'm not saying that everybody needs
to be out of multiple either.
If you're eating well and you're getting enough calories
a day, you're probably eating your main nutrition.
So, I'm not saying that everybody needs to be out of multiple,
either.
So, then you're just going to start looking at,
like, specifically, is there, like,
how am I deficient in minerals in the summer?
Am I deficient in B vitamins?
I mean, start looking at things like that.
I can give you, I will come up with a suggestion
and I'll email you a suggestion for a multivitamin mineral.
Struggle is that most of the multivitamins out there
have things like copper in them,
or they have antioxidants in them.
So, I will look and find one for you.
It's not very often that a person tests negative
for these things, but you did for some reason, I don't know.
So, I'll find it good for you, but I'll be right.